let's talk about the hidden cause of
palpitations now what is a palpitation
it's when your heartbeat races
temporarily it towns flip-flops skips or
flutters and a lot of people get freaked
out and they're scared realize that most
of time it is not going to be the
problem
but typically what will cause this would
be a fluctuation in your blood sugars
either having high blood sugar or low
blood sugar
maybe you consume some chocolate which
has two stimulants theobromine and
caffeine that can trigger your heart to
do certain things
caffeine especially too much will do it
alcohol having a fever or having low
electrolytes potassium or magnesium can
alter the rhythm of the heart but
there's another cause of palpitations
that I want to mention and that has to
do with your gallbladder there's an
interesting paper on this topic showing
the relationship between in the
gallbladder and an ECG reading
electrocardiogram so in other words if
you have gall stones or your gall
bladders distended the connecting to
between the liver and the small
intestine is dilating or you have sludge
in your gallbladder all of these can
alter the physiology of your heart that
can be shown on an ECG now I don't want
to get too far into the woods of a
certain pattern that would show up in
the ECG you can look this up if you're
interested but there's definitely a
change in the heart that occurs when
there's an issue with the gallbladder
now if someone has an abnormal ECG
reading it could definitely be a problem
with the heart but it can also be a
problem with the gallbladder and not the
heart now I'm just bringing this up
because the last thing you'd want to do
is some massively invasive procedure and
the problem is something else so I
always ask people what did you eat just
before you have these palpitations and
inevitably they ate something that they
normally don't eat or for example they
consumed a lot of heavy cream or
something new or chocolate or a lot of
caffeine
or alcohol but some new food was
introduced into the diet that then
aggravated the gallbladder and then
created these palpitations now if you
haven't seen my other videos in the
gallbladder here are some other common
symptoms right ribcage pain right
underneath your right ribcage you have a
fullness or a pain or it can be referred
to the right side of your head or the
right eye or the right trap or the right
shoulder or the right rhomboid area
which is a muscle on the right side
between this spine and your scapula
now another symptom to be a
light-colored stool or your stool floats
or your nauseated you get bloating
burping belching or even constipation
now the bio that is made in your liver
and stored in the gall bladder is a
lubricant so it prevents constipation if
you have too much bile you'll have
diarrhea if you have too little bile you
may have constipation so a lot of things
can alter bile the production in the
storage anybody should just explain what
vilest bile is a detergent that's made
by your body and it's used when you
digest fats it extracts certain things
from the fat fat Seibel vitamins vitamin
A E D and K it also extracts like
omega-3 fatty acids and other necessary
fats for your health and it's actually
the deficiency of bile that could
potentially produce gall stones and
sluggishness so a lot of that is diet
related but the point of this video is
just to make you more aware of another
potential cause of your palpitations of
gall bladder if you want more
information about the gall bladder I
have a lot of videos I would recommend
starting with this one right here